[Música]
hoy en directo a vamos a Ciudad de
Panamá donde inició el juicio por el
caso New business contra varios acusados
entre ellos el expresidente Ricardo
martinelli quien según la fiscalía
habría blanqueado capitales para comprar
con fondos públicos un conglomerado de
medios esto por alrededor de 44 millones
de dólares martinelli no estuvo presente
en la audiencia por una incapacidad
médica conectamos con Oscar sulbaranco
responsable de France 24 en la capital
panameña Óscar Qué ocurrió durante la
audiencia de hoy y quiénes son los
implicados
efectivamente como lo comentas el día de
hoy inició este juicio del denominado
caso
que involucra una compra o lavado de
dinero a través de una compra
presuntamente ilegal de
un conglomerado
un grupo editorial de el país la
principal
lo principal o lo más relevante del día
fue la ausencia de el expresidente
Ricardo martinelli tiene presentó una
incapacidad médica sin embargo la jueza
que lleva la causa rechazó la misma y
dijo que una vez iniciado este proceso
no podía seguir
retrasándose el mismo ya es la segunda
vez en este momento ya por segunda
ocasión
era la segunda vez que se llevaba a cabo
este
este juicio este inicio de juicio se
había llamado para el mes de abril sin
embargo sorprendió precisamente por una
situación
similar
el expresidente Ricardo Martínez y
también su defensa eh se mantuvo ausente
sin embargo un abogado sustituto se hizo
presente incluso eh solicitó la
que se fuera separado de la jueza de
este caso por mantener una presunta
relación hace algunos años atrás con
esta jueza todo esto en medio de un
panorama que faltando un año para las
elecciones presidenciales ya comienza a
agitarse en Panamá